ajuster son effort au sahel c'est la
déclaration ford emmanuel macron ce
mardi lors de ses voeux aux armées à
brest s'il défend le bilan des forces
françaises dans cette région pour lutter
contre les groupes jihadistes le
président estime qu'il est temps de
réduire le nombre de militaires sur
place une opération barkan qui compte
actuellement cinq mille cent hommes dont
six en envoyer il y a tout juste un an
les résultats obtenus par nos forces au
sahel
conjugué à l'intervention plus
importante de nos partenaires européens
pour nous permettre d'ajuster notre
effort mais 2020 a été une année de
résultats dans la zone des trois
frontières dans la lutte antiterroriste
et autour des différents piliers défini
à pau renforcer les capacités militaires
sahélienne accroître notre emprise dans
la lutte contre le terrorisme consolider
le retour des états une déclaration qui
intervient alors qu'une manifestation
contre la présence militaire française
au mali devait avoir lieu ce mercredi
avant d'être interdite pour des raisons
sanitaires
comme depuis plusieurs mois la société
civile et les associations dénoncent
l'engagement militaire de paris
effective depuis 2013 ce mercredi lors
d'une audition au sénat la ministre des
armées florence par ali a détaillé les
possibles ajustements à venir sur le
terrain nous avons en effet de nouveaux
drones qui sont arrivés sur le théâtre
libyen et tout est fait aujourd'hui pour
que l'ensemble des certificats
validation autorisations de vol puisse
être donnée afin de pouvoir tirer
pleinement parti de ces matériels avec
nos partenaires internationaux
notre présence n'est certainement pas
éternel et nous ne resterons que le
temps nécessaire pour que les forces
armées de nos amis et partenaires
sahélien soit en mesure de mener ce
combat elle même et pas un jour de plus
la france devrait officialiser une
première vague de retrait des troupes
françaises dans
du prochain sommet du g 500 elle qui
aura lieu au mois de février au tchad